hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
before we start this video i just wanted
to quickly mention that only 20
or so of you are subscribed so if you
enjoy regular harry potter content and
want to support the channel
then please consider subscribing in this
video i'm going to be discussing the
famed
hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry as well as the courses
that students take while attending the
school hogwarts was founded when four
10th century witches and wizards got
together
and decided that they had in the sorting
hat's own words
the self-same yearning to make the
world's best magic school these founders
were godric gryffindor rowena ravenclaw
salazar sutherin
and helga hufflepuff thus hogwarts was
born
the name hogwarts actually came from
founder rorina ravenclaw
who had a dream where a warty hog led
her to a cliff by a lake
it's also been speculated that this is
how they chose the location for the
school
after its establishment like with any
institution a crest was formed for
hogwarts
emblazoned upon the school crest are the
words draco
dormian nunclum titlandis which roughly
translates to
never tickle a sleeping dragon hogwarts
is in hagrid's words
the finest school of witchcraft and
wizardry in the world and the students
of hogwarts are taught under
in hagrid's words the finest headmaster
that hogwarts has ever seen
albus dumbledore so hogwarts produces
some impressive witches and wizards
but when a hogwarts student graduates
are they prepared for the real world
do they know as much about muggle
subjects as muggle graduates
are magical classes in addition to the
curriculum or a replacement
we know that hogsmeade is one of the
last settlements inhabited solely by
wizards
witches and other magical beings what
this possibly tells us is that many of
the hogwarts graduates will go on to
live amongst muggles in
non-magical communities and it really
seems like they should be prepared for
the environments that they're going to
end up living in
if they're only taught magic that would
probably be an issue at some point or
another
so hogwarts what do they teach in a
video that i made a couple of months ago
i discussed all 21 subjects taught at
hogwarts
however i'm not going to just
regurgitate all 21 courses from that
video
so i won't outline them here if you want
to check that one out i'll leave a link
in the description
what i am going to do however is single
out the courses that pertain to muggle
subjects
or have similarities with muggle
subjects first up is astronomy
these astronomy classes take place in
the astronomy tower the classes are led
by professor aurora sinistra
and much like in the muggle world these
astronomy lessons surround the
observations of the night sky
via telescope homework for this class
involves learning the names of stars
constellations and planets as well as
their location
movements and environments astronomy is
defined as follows
astronomy is a natural science that
studies celestial objects and phenomena
it uses mathematics physics and
chemistry in order to explain their
origin
and evolution objects of interest
include planets moons
stars nebula galaxies and comets
so really there's no need for hogwarts
to deviate or pivot on the subject of
astronomy
as magical concepts are not necessarily
applicable here it's actually one of the
only classes where use of magic is not
necessary
at all astronomy is a required class for
the first five years of study
and is optional in the last two harry
was taking his astronomy owl in 1996
when ruby's hagrid was confronted by
professor umbridge and a team of auras
in what was an attempted sacking this
was also the night that minerva
mcgonagall took
no less than four stannis to the chest
next up we have alchemy
alchemy is a sort of composite subject
which mixes transfiguration
potions and muggle chemistry it teaches
students about the disciplines of an
ancient magic
the study of the four basic elements
fire earth
water air and how to manipulate them for
the purpose of transmuting substances
however alchemy isn't taught to everyone
and pottermore states that
only some students are allowed to study
alchemy at hogwarts and receive
special instruction in that discipline
pottermore also discusses the
relationship between alchemy and moral
chemistry
so while it's not purely a magical
subject the study of alchemy should have
some transfer of the chemochemistry next
up we have muggle studies
we can easily derive that this class is
more of a muggle subject from the name
muggle studies was taught by charity
burbidge and a different version of it
was later taught by maletto carra
which involves the study of muggle
culture from a wizarding point of view
this subject can be sub-categorized into
muggle art
and muscle music the intention for this
class was to teach witches and wizards
about muckle culture so that they can
blend in when they need to
i think this course is of particular
importance if witches and wizards are
eventually wanting to reside
in non-magical communities next up is
herbology
well sort of herbology is taught by
professor pomona sprout
and it looks at the study of magical
plants and how to take care of them
however at hogwarts there are many
greenhouses which hold a variety of
plants
and i'm willing to bet that at least
some of them are not magical
if you look at the list of known potion
ingredients in harry potter lexicon
you will find ingredients that are
naturally occurring in the world
and are not necessarily magical next up
is arithmancy
sort of arithmancy is a branch of magic
concerned with the magical properties of
numbers
it's hermione's favorite subject and
there is an advanced offering for the
class
i'd like to think that arithmancy mainly
covers arithmetic
but in reality it likely has more of a
focus on numerology
we know that numerology is important in
harry potter particularly the
significance of the number 7
which seems to show up everywhere
however i'm sure that a foundation of
mathematical knowledge is required for
this course
and i'm sure in the earlier years of
taking it students are eased into the
numerology side
and more of an emphasis is placed on the
arithmetic side
last up we have ancient runes the study
of ancient runes is taught by professor
bathushida babbling
it is a theoretical subject that
involves studying for ancient runic
scripts
i say that this course isn't necessarily
magical because runes are found in the
muggle world
and are not exclusive to the wizarding
world taking the subject while not
necessarily massively practical in
everyday
life could help someone pursue a career
in archaeology
or something of the sort so these are
the only subjects from which i can
extract
potential muggle application however i'm
sure there's a lot that goes on behind
the scenes
by the time most students have started
at hogwarts they've already received
some level of education either by
homeschooling or attending muggle
primary school
it was this introduction to schooling
that gave them their academic base
and it is of my impression that the
topics at hogwarts bridge back to these
foundational subjects
in many ways there are many professions
in the wizarding world
and if we look at a core subject like
english as an example
we can link lots of magical careers that
would rely heavily on this subject
journalists for the daily prophets head
of the aura office politicians like the
minister of magic
all of these professions would seemingly
require a higher than primary school
knowledge of english
the skill of writing is reinforced at
hogwarts through essay writing
but it's important to note that most of
the subject matter is magical
not to muggle so my thought is that
these foundational subjects are mixed
into the curriculum
wherever possible or applicable maybe
they just aren't discussed because
they're not particularly exciting
whichever way you look at it some
professions are going to require math
english and or science whether they're
magical in nature or not
so it makes no sense that students will
grow into adulthood with no knowledge of
these subjects
canon never actually dictates how a
magical child would receive
advanced instruction in math or science
at hogwarts
and while i don't feel that there's
necessarily a huge emphasis on these
topics in the curriculum
i think that there is perhaps more
happening behind the scenes than we are
aware of additionally i would expect
that those who desire to learn more
about these subjects
would have the opportunity to do so
through apprenticeships
or perhaps in some instances through
tailored instruction
and that's it for this video i hope you
guys enjoyed it did i miss any subjects
do you think that muggle subjects are
perhaps emphasized
a little more behind the scenes let me
know down in the comment section
below until next time remember there is
plenty to be learned
even from a bad teacher what not to do
how not to be
you